[Music]
hi everyone i'm
really excited to be here so let's start
um i personally believe that the future
of knowledge work will eventually be
remote
so in some sense we all got to
experience the future
in the last few months however this
might not have been
what you hoped for because setting up a
collaborative environment for your data
science team can be challenging
even when working side by side in an
office
at apsilom we spent years developing
efficient
systems for remote collaboration and in
this presentation
i will cover the best practices that
work for us
so i'm olgamish vasulima and i'm a
senior data scientist
and an experienced project leader at
opsion i have a background
in econometrics and my main
technological
stuck at work is r
i have been building our community here
in warsaw
since 2014
in i plan to cover three areas in my
talk
so project management doing effective
code reviews
and setting up a painless development
environment in
r so when it comes to project management
almost all of the projects that we run
an app still on
are managed with scrum approach with
small variations
at the beginning of the project we sit
down
together with our client and collect the
requirements
that are translated to high level tasks
in the project backlog
at this stage we also provide a high
level estimates on how much time we
think we need
for example we contract work for eight
weeks
each with one week long sprint
every sprint starts with a sprint
planning
where the dev team and
the client select the task to work in a
given week
and we also set the varieties
during the week we meet daily inside the
deaf team
to give each other updates we also
use those meetings as an opportunity to
catch up on the small things that are
happening
inside the team because we don't have
those random
meetings in adults that happen next to
the coffee machine
the rest of the communication during the
week we try to do async
using a dedicated project channel on
slack
we also use slack to give each other
updates
such as that we start or finish work or
are in the do not disturb mode
we also hold one-on-ones between
team members to discuss specific
problems
related to the project but coming back
to our scrum process
at the at the end of the week uh we do
the sprint review
where we show to our client the
increment usually this means
doing a demo of a shiny app with new
teachers
or going through a notebook and it
validates
new data science hypothesis we also
hold retrospective meetings to celebrate
things that went well
or to discuss potential improvements
we used project board to help us manage
backlog
we usually usually you use tools
available
from github asana or jira
so agile development is standard and
common tactics but making it work
for your team is it is a clue so we make
sure
to always have well organized project
board
that is reflecting reflecting the
current status of work
so basically if i look into the project
board
it should tell me who is working on what
tasks and what are the varieties
also at absilum we have this rule that
all
work needs to be documented so whatever
you are doing
there should be a corresponding task
describing it on the project
board the task needs to have a clear and
informative description
which is understandable not only to the
deaf team
but also to our clients as they have
access to the project board as well
we introduced an implementation plan
which is something
that is non-standard to a classical
kanban view
basically the person who is doing the
task
has to provide a description how they
will approach the task and get an
acceptance from another team member
before starting the actual
implementation
this way we make sure that any proposed
change makes sense
and we verify it early enough finally
the reviewer is responsible to check if
the solution
corresponds to the task requirements
as you probably noticed our product
management flow
is tightly related to code review i will
assume that majority of you are familiar
with that concept and i will only talk
what
makes it effective we have a checklist
that is part of our definition
of done for a task and includes the
following points
all the code needs to be peer reviewed
and there are no exceptions from this
rule
so even fixing a typo in the
documentation needs to be peer reviewed
uh we also make sure that continuous
integration checks
are such as linked their unit test
integration tests are configured and
passed
next any added or modified code
has to follow our style guide this is
especially important
because it allows us to ensure quality
do more effective code reviews
learn from each other and split backs in
the code more easily
next all the change all the changes and
needs to be tested manually or with
automated tests
further we need to make sure that no new
errors or warnings have been introduced
and that readme documentation and code
comments
had been updated according to the change
we try to automate as many things as
possible
and we use a continuous integration with
github
actions to perform automatic checks and
let the machines
do the job for example we automatically
run unit tests
after every code push
we also use project templates to
initialize the reference structure
for typical project types and use fully
request templates that contains
a definition of done checklists from the
previous slide
to help reviewer do the review
so finally we can talk about the
development environment
it's the most crucial part when working
in r
otherwise the same code can give
different results on different machines
other projects can be affected as in a
global environment
shared packages can change and crush
unrelated projects
deployment can give you a real headache
because establishing infrastructure can
be challenging if it's not being tracked
and last but not least your team members
will waste time
setting up an environment rather than
jumping straight to work
this might not be a problem when
starting a new project
but imagine adding a new team a member
in the middle
or at the end of the project to solve
all of those issues
we do the development in our studio
running inside a docker container
which is fixed and dedicated per project
we leverage docker and rents to control
underlying system
system dependencies and our packages
docker and
runs package together makes new
collaboration
easy all the changes to a docker file
or rent log file that records packages
used in the project are committed and
pushed to docker hub
or github from where they can be
accessed by other
team members
previous solution however still requires
some level of devops skills to set up
everything
so some of our clients choose
rstudio server because it allows their
data science team
to purely focus on delivering value
using their core competencies
in a highly secure and flexible
development environment
there is no secret recipe to make your
data science team work efficiently
in fact we found that using scrum with
well-organized project board
doing code reviews and taking care of
the development environment
is essential for project success no
matter how your team is structured
thank you very much and next
my colleague pedro will tell you how to
build a dashboard
that can speak for itself when dealing
with users adoption you can
always be next to them and you you
cannot always be next to them and
explain
how your app will work it's even more
difficult
when working remotely so
uh i think one uh very important thing
when it comes to
remote teams is that uh you're not
always building dashboards
for uh for external users you're
sometimes also building dashboards for
your own teams to work in and uh like
olga said
when you're in the office and you're
next to someone uh
it's very easy to just push them in the
right direction of how to use it
but if you don't have this direct
contact with
with your users you end up having
a good solution for this is to put a bit
of extra work into your dashboards and
actually
make them speak by speak for themselves
uh especially when there's alternative
dashboards
users typically have a choice and they
will
usually go for the one that feels better
so small background
from me i used to work as a web
developer so
i used to pages i used to do
applications and eventually
in the last couple of years i landed in
r and in shiny so one of the great
things that
um i ended up learning about chinese
that
deep down there's a lot of javascript a
lot of css a lot of html involved
so this actually allows you to
allow me to reuse a lot of what i used
as a web developer to actually
work on shiny dashboards uh so
why does ui actually matter the
the question is if you have a dashboard
that works why should you actually care
about making it look nicer and
the truth is that uh ui
the way your dashboard looks and feels
is
very important for your users so this is
the the first experience that your users
are going to get
uh using your application and
especially now that everyone is so used
to
the way the internet works the way the
the
applications in the phone in your phones
and tablets work
users expect things to behave in a
specific way
it's also very important to notice that
users don't usually care
what's in the background and this is
valid even for some shiny apps if
if your users use the application to
get a specific insight or to get some
some
data they don't really want to they they
don't really need to know how
complicated the background process
processes they want to have a nice
experience
they want to be
quick and efficient at using it and
in general you end up with
with this this concept that if users
don't feel engaged and comfortable when
they use your application
uh they might get frustrated they might
stop using it maybe they will
pick a different alternative if it's
possible
so instead of going over the whole ui
and what you can do uh i decided to give
you a couple of things that you can look
uh adds a couple of uh
parts of the application that you can
keep in mind either when you're using an
application or you're giving feedback on
when or when you're actually building
the application
uh so i picked six very important topics
uh very very important points when it
comes to ui the first one is
you should keep your interface simple it
means
any element that isn't actually doing
anything
you should probably remove it it also
means
cleaning up your dashboards also means
that uh you'll
pass a very clear message of what you're
trying your users to
of what you want your users to achieve
uh you
end up with something that is very
straight to the point uh because
all the elements there actually serve
some functionality
another important tip is to be
consistent
so if you have a text input reuse it if
you have a button reuse it
users kind of learn to navigate your
your application so they expect elements
to have the same kind of behavior
they expect flows to uh work the same
way
and you can you can kind of define
patterns of how
your application flows when you have
very complex applications
uh another thing to keep in mind is to
be
forcefully purposeful in your layout and
this basically means that
just because all the information is
there doesn't mean that
it's being shown in a good way
so adding white space where there's no
information
is important uh using using the ui
elements to actually create some kind
of structure and in the case of
dashboards this is
the site partner the sidebar navigation
the the top navigation all of these
can help you create a bit of structure
when it comes to your dashboard
it also means that you can draw
attention to important information
you can you can use colors you can use
uh
the size of the elements to actually
change the way that your
users perceive parts of it uh
other one is you there's a few
really good things that you can
manipulate when it comes to
to any kind of web application these are
color texture and typography
so work work with these uh
don't overdo it when it comes to color
when it comes to contracts when it comes
to shadows
use them to
kind of attract your users to specific
points of the application
or to make things less less evident and
less important
from from from your application uh
remember that different
fonts send different messages so
bold large phones uh
are a different message from small
very non-bright phones for example
and also remember that the size of the
font the the
way the text is arranged it really helps
people
go through your application and be more
efficient at their work
uh also remember to provide feedback
uh you want your users to always know
where they are
what they're doing if the application is
still doing something or not
using messages progress bars
anything that gives some kind of
feedback feedback of what's happening
really helps reducing the frustration
especially when you have
scripts that are running for very long
times or you're
uploading a lot of data uh you don't
want your user to think that the app
just crashed
or that something is wrong keep them
uh looks like we might have lost audio
for a second
let's see pedro
are you able to hear us it looks like we
might have lost your audio
oh pedro are you back yes i'm sorry
there we go we lost a minute
oh uh do you want me to go back for a
second or
uh yeah i we missed the past the like
two minutes of what you were saying
oh okay uh so let's from
okay okay so uh yeah so i was saying
that
uh it's also very important to provide
feedback to your users
um this is
you don't want your users to know uh
that
your app uh you want you want users to
to be
aware of what's happening with the app
this this usually means
using progress bars using messages using
notifications
uh you should always provide some kind
of feedback
to make sure that your users don't get
lost or
are waiting for some very long process
some very long script that's running
and they have no idea what's happening
uh if if you have
something that you know is going to take
more than a few seconds uh
odds are the progress bar if you have
something that can be done in the
background while your user
is using the the application
uh make a pop maybe show a notification
when
when uh when it's over uh all of this
kind of constant feedback really helps
when it comes to the to the user
experience
and finally remember to think about the
default values
uh shiny dashboards live of inputs
of user user inputs and
a lot of the times these inputs can be
defaulted to some values that are very
common for users to use
uh if you have a drop down but you know
that's most commonly this is the value
that's used
uh add the value to that drop down or
pre-select the drop down if you have a
checkbox that most of the time is
selected
uh select it by default anything that
avoids
unnecessary actions by the user and can
make the experience much faster and much
smoother
so how do you actually achieve all of
these things so uh
there's two ways of of going at it uh
the the the easy and quick way is uh use
ui packages so
we're all familiar with shiny and it's
it's
default ui but you you can for example
use shiny dashboard to completely change
the way the application looks
and some of these ui tips are already
implemented in the
the actual elements provided by shiny
dashboard
another good package is shiny semantic
uh
this is based on a different uh css
framework
but it also comes with a lot of elements
that
you don't really need to think about
some of these uh
of these uh tips uh but you already have
some elements that already include them
uh another option is that you can just
create your own
um your your own layouts your
own uh styles and i
i'm giving you here three very uh
common examples that i use so uh maybe
you found some
some html template online that you would
like to use
uh use html templates this is a function
that just lets you
import a full html uh
file to your shiny application uh do you
want to style something uh use css
if you if you have a lot of styles and
you want to go very deep into the
into changes uh you can even try sas
which is
basically a preprocessor for css it's
css for developers let's say
uh do you want to add custom behavior
that isn't default out of the box
uh if you're building something very
complex you can try html widgets
but for very simple behaviors you can
even use uh just vanilla javascript with
with a couple of uh of actions
uh and
these are some examples of very popular
uh packages that were done using html
widgets for example so you can see that
these are uh standards for
for what we currently use as developers
and
there's they are very they're actually
very easy to use
uh so i'll just quickly finish with a
couple of examples of what you can
actually do so
uh this is an example of
uh just the dashboard that started as a
simple shiny dashboard
uh we then implemented we then added
shiny semantic
a bit of custom styling and we got a
completely different different feel for
the actual dashboard uh
another example and there's a link in
the bottom
uh i actually did a couple of months ago
the whole idea of going from
uh just a base shiny um
dashboard into a full fully uh complete
custom solution so the dashboard started
like this
i didn't did some testing with chinese
dashboard where the
feeling was completely different with
just a few changes uh
semantic dashboard also completely
different
uh feeling and then we ended up with a
super with a completely custom built
solution
uh with a lot of css a lot of uh custom
javascript
and even a team switch here so
you could in general the the limit is
your imagination
and uh just as a final final example
this was my entry for this year's shiny
contest
uh there's a blog link in the bottom
that you can follow if you want to
read a bit more about all the
technologies everything that
actually went into this this is actually
this is a shiny dashboard
i promise you uh if you don't believe me
uh
you can check the github uh
yeah and that's it for me and i will be
passing it
to damian which will be who will be
talking about
scaling and just how
much can you push when it comes to
scaling uh shiny
applications thank you pedro
so yeah it's amazing we we are going
through a journey together
when it comes to working remotely um in
my part i would like to share with you
how you can scale a shiny dashboard so
let's take a look at
first let me introduce myself my name is
daniel javish i'm
one of the founders of epsilon i have
worked with many different languages
like scala c
sharp python c plus plus and javascript
and i always like to combine all the
knowledge from different technologies
and
apply it to aren't shiny i must say that
throughout my experience i have never
seen
a language with a library that are so
fast to
build great looking applications that
are then used in production
so short agenda i'm going to start with
an introduction that then i will give
you an overview of the scaling
and some details on how you make how you
can make your
applications faster with just a few
simple rules
so this is you and your team thanks to
olga talk and your knowledge you already
built
the workflow for for your for your team
and
knowing shiny and making your
application beautiful
you deploy an application that is
available in production for your users
and then you start having people using
it
first this is one person suddenly there
is a little bit more of them
and you get the feedback and i really
like this slide because it sums up our
experience
uh when we talk to different clients
there is always someone who
created like this new fresh change in
the company they introduced shiny they
suddenly built an application that
everyone likes
and people just love the application the
features are added fast because of the
fact that shine is so robust
and the application does exactly what
people need in their daily job
and probably a lot of you know this well
however suddenly you have so many people
using your application
uh that the application starts getting
slow and this is usually when we
jump in and help companies organize
their code and to make sure that they
can scale
to a lot of people because the fact is
that
shiny is fast rcd connect is fast and
allows you to
scale even up to 10 000 users but it
needs to be implemented
in a given way with a given in
architecture and i'm going to share with
you
uh what has to be done in order to
achieve such scaling
so first of all let's look at shiny
there are two ways that you can scale
your application the first one is
vertical scaling
this is increasing the amount of users
that you have for one machine
and the other part is horizontal scaling
which means adding as many machines as
you want
just to make sure that the application
runs for covers for
as many people as you want so one thing
to know is that you should first work on
vertical scaling
so that your application is fast and and
very robust
and then you can add as many machines as
you want otherwise you're going to use a
lot of resources
so for the first one there are
three basically key
things that you can do first one is
leverage front-end
which is to use javascript to handle
fast user interactions
that do not change the data and that's
so that you don't have to actually
communicate with the server that often
uh the second part is to extract
computations uh to handle
the resource intensive operations away
from the application
and so that
excuse me quick check um
so that the server itself isn't that
overloaded
with the computations and the third one
is to set the right architecture that
i'm going to show you as well
one thing that you should keep in mind
is if you want your shiny application to
be
fast and if you want it to work for many
users
you should make sure that the shiny
layer is thin
this should be a communication interface
between the data and the ui so
the interface so this is really what we
see
when we join different companies and
work with them there is a server there
is ui and there is plenty of
communication happening
between the front end and the back end
and
what you should be doing to make your
application fast is
first you should make sure that a lot of
operations that do not
meet any communication with server
happen on the front end
and that the server actually calls the
external services to fetch the data
and to filter the data there not inside
of the memory of
your machine and then you can add as
many machines as you want
so let's take a look at the first one
leveraging the front end
few very simple things that you can do
to already scale
your application um i'm going to go
through them
very briefly first one render inputs in
ui
and only update them in server.r this is
a very simple thing that you can already
apply to your applications
very often people create a ui output in
the ui
and then they put all of the rendering
in the backend
this requires re-rendering the whole
widget whenever the input
whenever the other inputs change and
this makes the application slower
what instead you can do is you can
render the numeric input on the
front-end
and only update the inputs on the server
very simple change already gives you a
lot of leverage
second part you can inline javascript
code with chinese.js package
by the natali a very simple thing allows
you to call javascript
right from the server and you don't have
to generate the whole html on the
backend
but you can just ask javascript to
toggle some changes
in the ui without actually going back
and forth
and the the third one is to set all
actions in javascript without
server.rpart
so when you create for example an action
button you can right away create an
on-click hook
for the javascript call and
what is important here is that if you
have skilled people
in your team and you have created a
great application that is used by a lot
of people
and you want that your team members to
grow
the javascript is a natural next step
for them to learn
to make the applications robust look
better and move faster
let's talk about extracting computations
first idea is to use a remote api
and plumber from our studio is a great
package to do that
so when you think about your application
you shouldn't load the entire data
set to your application instead you can
ask external services
to filter the data for you and you just
show the user the
excerpt of the data that is useful
because very often as pedro mentioned
you don't need to put too much
information to the user they just want
to see what they need
then you can very easily wrap data
extraction logic into a simple api
with plumber this is done just by adding
special comments
there is a great documentation about it
so
make sure that you check it out if you
don't know plumber and what is really
important is that you can easily deploy
this
with our studio connect so just as you
have your applications running on our
studio connect
with a click of a button you can also
deploy api and
many applications can actually use the
same api which allows you to
reuse your code across many different
projects
side note make sure to use efficient
data libraries
because very often when you have an api
you want to share some data and you
very often also read it from the from
the disk
actually there are many different
packages for reading data and you can
read a huge amount of data without
affecting
the memory of the system a lot so make
sure you check out those packages
and check how they actually improve
their performance sometimes
just changing the library that you use
for manipulating data
can unblock a lot of potential in our
application
so for the extracting computations the
second part that is very often
[Music]
important and crucial for the for the
applications is to start using a
database
success story usually starts with a
simpler application and the data is just
loaded into memory
looks fine i have a ui i have data and
then i have server that
filters the data and shows the results
to the user
just a simple application however if the
file is big like for example one
gigabyte
it's going to cause you some trouble uh
first
when you have just five users rc connect
is going to distribute them evenly
uh between processes and they are not
going to use for example three gigabytes
of ram
um if you have 13 users it can get a
little bit more but
the machine is going to handle it well
however the more users
use your application the more processes
you have to create
and each process is going to keep the
same object in the memory
so it is crucial for you to instead of
putting all of the data into memory
to put it away to a database and to
just use filter methods and different
selections
to get the data that you need and then
your machine is going to be very light
very thin and you can have a huge amount
of users using your application and the
database is going to handle all of them
um also important thing to know is that
you can use db player
to use different filtering just as you
are manipulating data with the
player so let's talk about the
architecture
we all know shiny server open source it
allows us to very quickly deploy the
application
um right away after you deploy the
application you will see that rsd
connect
is a great choice to have multiple
processes
to have better control on how users use
your application
and it also has a great functionality of
being able to deploy the applications
with a single click of a button
what we like to use on our site is we
use ansible
to improvising the whole infrastructure
so imagine you have a bare metal
machine with ansible you can install all
of the packages that are needed for
studio connect then you can install r
studio connect
and then you can even deploy the
application because you have a great
package
rs connect which has the whole api to
deploy
applications from the command line uh so
really um
i i think that everyone who does the
development on a high scale on a big
scale
using ansible is a really good choice
now this is the architecture that you
would have for your applications you set
up multiple servers
and they all have to be behind the load
balancer with a sticky session
and they all have to connect to the same
database they have the authentication
mechanism and the shirt disk
as a bonus there is also a great option
uh that you can use
so that for example you can have an
offline mobile application
uh that is using uh end points that are
deployed to
our studio connect with plumber so this
is also something that we have done
successfully so there is plenty of
things that you can do
and i encourage you to try them you may
think that this is all
um of course this is all from me but
when you think about it
you know how to create the application
you know how to make it beautiful
you know how to collaborate with your
team and then you can even scale it
but now comes the big thing because when
you have
such success then you want to share this
success with others
and that is how that is why alex is
going to tell you
what you can do to actually go beyond
one single project
and actually make this collaboration
fruitful for everyone
thank you awesome thanks damian
i will share my screen here now and
start presenting
great um hey everybody uh thanks so much
to all of my co-presenters uh damian
pedro and and olga for like leading us
uh uh through the the better part of
this hour i'm super excited to sort of
close out here and talk a little bit
about um let me make sure i have the
right click there we go
about growing a remote data science team
uh my name is alex gold i'm a solutions
engineer at
rstudio uh and if you feel like tweeting
at me my twitter is down there
on the bottom uh so let's let's jump
right in growing remote data science
team
uh just tell you a little about me this
is my face uh since you can't see it on
the video right now more importantly
this is my puppy she's much cuter than i
am um
and uh so so my background is i before i
came to r studio i was a data scientist
um and a data science team lead now here
at our studio i work as a solutions
engineer and what that means
is that i spend my time helping teams
figure out how to make the most of open
source data science tools like r and
python
and how to make the most of our studio
professional tools um so
what i'm talking about here is sort of a
combination of things that i learned as
a data science team lead
and also some things i've seen out in
the wild throughout my time here at
r studio so let's start by talking a
little bit about like
what it means to grow a data science
team and so
there are really four ways i think about
growing a data science team so the first
is just straight up size right like
the number of people on the team is one
way to grow a
data science team you can also grow a
data science team in terms of velocity
right like what is the output per person
how much are you churning out how much
work are you getting done how many
models are you creating that that sort
of thing
um another way you can sort of scale a
data science team is in terms of
reliability right are you confident that
the outputs that you're putting out are
are correct um are you confident that
they're they're what they need to be
and then of course sophistication right
and that that could mean maybe
graduating to using
uh more advanced machine learning models
or things like that or maybe it just
means
um you know going from using mostly
excel to using more code tools that can
be a really great way to sort of
um you know grow a team in in particular
ways so
what i'm going to spend the balance of
my time talking about today is is
actually a
tool uh that i think can really help
with with all of these things and that
tool of course is the r
package um some of you might be like
wait what you're just going to talk
about our packages but i i want to take
a little step back so instead of talking
about like
the mechanics of our packages right like
how do you write in our package i'm not
going to talk about that there's lots of
great stuff that's been written about it
um i really recommend like hadley
wickham's book if if you're curious
that's that's a great resource
uh but what i want to talk about is the
r package as a tool
to grow a data science team how does the
art package work for us
not what is the art package but let's
start off just like describing for
anybody who's not super familiar like
what is uh in our package
so in our is a way to sort of uh
container up package up
a bunch of functions that you use
commonly in r like
much like you could put a dachshund in a
cardboard box and it would be nicely
contained
a package is a way to contain uh a bunch
of our functions that sort of hang
together
for for some reason and so i i want to
talk about like two different ways to
use
our packages uh on your data science
team to help it grow
and so the first way is the team wide
our package so this is when uh your team
writes one or sometimes a few sometimes
the team will have several depending on
what you're doing
are packages that are for specific
things and they're used across the team
and so the
the kinds of things you might like have
in those r packages like maybe you have
particular analytical functions
that you use certain machine learning
models maybe you like always weight your
regressions the same way or something
like that
um and and that can go you know those
functions can go in our package
maybe you have certain plotting defaults
you use a lot right maybe you use the
same templates or maybe you actually
have the same types of plots
you're creating a lot and putting those
those plotting functions in our package
can really help
um maybe you have templates you can put
code templates in our package you can
also put our markdown templates in
our package which i think is a really
cool use of our package right like you
could have a report template that is the
same way that you use every time put it
in a package
now everybody across the team has it and
then the last part of
you know things that that are really
great in team-wide r packages are data
accessing functions right like maybe you
have particular
ways you use dbi the dbi package or odbc
and
and wrapping that in our package means
that like not everybody has to remember
how it works they can just use the
function in the r package and that's
that's really handy so
this is what goes in the team right our
package but as i said like
we're not going to focus so much on the
mechanics like what then is this our
package
for and and to me a team wide r package
is really for three purposes the first
is
size right it's it's for scaling your
team particularly now that we're remote
like you can't sit next to somebody and
talk them through like this is how we do
an analysis
and so the documentation and the
functions in our package are a really
great tool
to onboard new people to your team
um and our package is also a really
great tool for increasing velocity
on your team uh you know if you have if
you have functions in there that sort of
you know make your work much easier and
particularly if you with every project
you go back and improve that r package a
little bit
that's going to make the the work just
you know every product is going to get
easier and easier and easier as that our
package
gets developed further and of course
sophistication right uh
if you have say one person on your team
who's just a really great r coder you
can take advantage
of of their skills across the entire
team or if you have like one really
great machine learning engineer
right if they if they write those those
specialized machine learning functions
everybody can use them all all of a
sudden so like to me the teamwide r
package
is really a tool for onboarding and
upskilling like that's
that's the purpose of the teamwide r
package um
i do want to give you two keys to making
this work for you though uh so so the
first key
is that everyone contributes to the r
package by having everyone on the team
contribute
you get much more buy-in people are
excited right they're excited to use
their own work they're excited to use
the team's work and
and having that team-wide r package is a
really really valuable
um uh resource in that case that they
will actually get used
and the second key which is way more
important is that your
teamwide r package must have a clever
name using the capital letter r this is
not optional
it is required uh but i will give you a
hint uh blank blank
help r is always available so you know
you have no excuse for not having a
clever name using the capital letter r
okay so that's the pattern of the
teamwide r package or our packages
uh another really popular pattern is the
package per
project that is like every analytical
project gets
its own r package and this is a really
really great pattern as well um and
but to to me again right like the the
the teamwide r package is about
upscaling
uh scaling and and upskilling uh the the
package per project is really about
reliability that is that it allows you
to document what you're doing in a much
more thorough way
and it allows you to test what you're
doing in a much more thorough way
when you put those functions into a
package as opposed to just sort of
using them uh in in in your analysis and
and just sort of having them that way
so uh i i do want to go through this in
just in just a little like more detail
here which is that
uh you know so so this is how i would
structure
a project that i were using this like
our package per project
uh structure and so what what i would
have here is i have my like
top level uh uh project directory right
so that would be like the whole project
we encapsulated in this
incidentally if i'm using a git repo i
would put it at the level of the whole
project uh you know you can have sort of
these
subdirectories inside one git repo
inside that though i'd have these two
subdirectories right out of the package
and the project and have those separate
from each other and i'll come back to
that in a second but they're sort of
parallel
to each other right the the package and
the project get developed in parallel
and and you know
something like dev tools load all is
your friend here while you're while
you're working on this
um and then you have your your right
your project functions go inside your
your r directory and this is where
right like you can put your oxygen
documentation you can actually document
all of the functions you're using in
your analysis and that's that's a really
great thing to be able to have that
documented for when you come back to it
later
and of course then you can also use
tests right and being able to unit test
your code is
is really important and this is actually
really important beyond just sort of
reliability that that you know you care
about so like maybe you just want to
make your
your projects more reliable across the
board and that's that's a really great
thing to do but also like
in some places there are requirements
that everything be tested before go to
production
this is a really great way to pull some
of those tests out of an interactive
mode and put them somewhere
that you can actually run a script and
so this is one of the really great
things about the project our package per
project
um model then of course you have your
actual you know whatever the actual work
is
of your project then sit separately from
that right that's in your
you know you might have an r markdown
document you might have an app.r you
might have some dot r files you might
have
uh you know a plumber api like like
dummy and talk right all kinds of things
can go here
uh but that's separate from the package
and and so i want to stick on this point
for a minute if if any of you are on
like
our studio our stats twitter uh there's
been a really great discussion the last
few days of like
should each project be a package
not like should each like right the
project uh
the package per project is should the
project have a package and i would say
yes
there's also this whole debate of should
the project be a package and my argument
is no
on that i just want to make it clear
because i spent like this you know the
last eight minutes just saying packages
are amazing
as a tool for for developing your team
but i don't think every package should
be a project
mainly because you end up with a lot of
weird metadata on your project that
doesn't work quite right
you can end up with some sort of weird
circular dependencies for where the
package depend on it depends on itself
to do stuff in itself and that
that's really messy um and also you can
end up in a state where your package
isn't actually installable that's not a
great place to be so
i would recommend the package can can be
a great tool
team wide to share functions across
people
it can be a great tool for increasing
the reliability of an individual project
it's not meant to be a whole project but
that's not the intent of our package and
i would argue at least and there are
others who will argue
uh very intelligently to the country but
i will argue that uh you should not have
your entire project
be in our package okay thank you so much
for for tuning in just
a couple you know my high level
takeaways our packages
are a tool for scaling and skilling uh
your remote data science team a team
wide package is a great tool for
increasing size velocity and
sophistication
and a per project package is a great
tool for increasing the reliability
of your work um with that i'm going to
pull back up this slide
from sam and i'll hand it over to her
to close us out
all righty wonderful thank you so much
alex and thank you so much to all of the
presenters i thought that was a really
fantastic story
um starting from how to build a team to
the actual tools you need down to what
to be successful
um so let's go ahead and jump into some
questions here
i've got a few uh plugged in
um we've got the first one here saying
could you elaborate i think this is
going to be for olga
could you elaborate on how people
technically work together
using rm docker and git lab
what's the operational pipeline here to
use as a best practice
um so usually
uh how we uh how we do the development
is that we when the project starts
um so at the beginning we built a
dedicated
docker container for each project
and inside the the docker container
we we set up an r studio so we do the
development inside the docker container
and to keep track
of all of the packages and their
versions
and to make the collaboration for the
users easy
we use rent package which is a
package available from our studio
and whenever there is a whenever we
install a new package we install it uh
to rent so the the rent log file
is updated and um
later when we uh when we finish the work
we we need to do the either we do
we commit all the changes so we commit
both
the the docker container and the changes
to the code
and we can either we commit them if we
use
a github then we do it to github or
gitlab it doesn't really matter
which uh
which service you use and
and the uh the the docker file
uh the new snapshot or
you can also rebuild uh the docker image
is
pushed to the docker hub repository so
basically
uh this uh this is our workflow
and how to exactly uh set up brand
with docker and there is a vignette
available
uh from rent package that
more or less describes how to do this
just wanted to quickly add something
very often we
we also have a base image that already
contains
cached libraries that you very often use
and multiple projects can
use this image as a as a base
so that you don't have to install
everything from scratch so this is also
something that we recommend if you want
to have reproducibility across your team
that's great thank you so much and um
and in that are you
olga are you using rstudio desktop or
our studio server our studio server pro
what does your tooling look like there
well
this really depends um so either we
are using uh the our studio desktop
or a uh also
um we can simplify this workflow as well
so
get rid of the docker but then
we are usually working with
our studio server pro
but then we still use rent to take care
of the
[Music]
the control over the packages um
but it really depends uh from
from what actually our clients want to
achieve
let's see that's great thank you and
then let's see i'm just looking at
making sure we got questions for
everyone
um i see here i believe this one
is for damian um so what recommendations
can you make when the dashboard requires
permissions and content dependent on
user viewing the dashboard
follow up on that is ldap a good fit
here or
what other ldap or other authentication
sources might you use
so i think that we there are
two ways of handling the access to the
data
like one part of course is
authentication so who is allowed to
access
the application and with rco connect you
can actually hook up to
any service that you have internally in
your company
very often companies use ldap to have
the same users the same passwords and
you can also have single sign-on and all
the all the other
good things with our studio connect um
when it comes to
our authorization it means that you can
have two users logged into the same
application but they see
different parts of the app and usually
this is something
that you have to implement yourself
within the application by
assigning roles within the app with the
business contacts that you have
one quick thing i'll just add to what
damian said which is exactly right is
that
one of the ways you can do that inside
connect is that you get
in the session data you get the user and
the groups so that's one of the ways
that you can sort of
take that data in a running session and
then pass it along to
uh you know you use it to to do
authorization is that you actually get
that data
inside the session
exactly that's the very good point
that's great thank you um so now let's
quickly jump to
the some package talk i'm sure everyone
loves that
so alex what are your recommendations
when functionality should be extracted
from a project specific
package to a team-wide package
oh that's that's a great a great
question um my
my favorite reference here is um uh
david robinson who's a data scientist
and sort of big in the in the our stats
community he has a very
he he said repeats says and repeats you
know if you
that you should do a lot of work in
public and if you if you say something
three times to somebody
you should put it in a blog post uh and
my my sort of corollary to that is that
if you
find yourself using the same function
three times you should put it in a
package
so that that would sort of be my my
recommendation right is like uh
you know certainly if you have three
projects where you're using the same
function you should probably extract
that into
into a package uh i would say sometimes
even two is worth it
uh but but to me really the flag is just
like do i want to use this package
use this function more than once or
twice uh then it belongs in sort of a
team-wide package
for the per project package kind of
pattern um you don't necessarily need to
reuse it sometimes the testing in the
documentation
is worth extracting it into you know
that that package all by itself
but if you're thinking about you know
obviously you want to keep the name
space of your package somewhat compact
and so uh you know uh waiting until you
need it two or three times to pull it in
is is often worthwhile
if i may add to this um the the great
tool that you can use a product is our
studio package manager
which is basically a copy of cron within
your own organization that you control
and you can install all of the packages
there and this allows you to share
this one package which is private to
your organization to everyone within the
organization
so be sure to check it out
that's great thank you damian so i think
we've got enough time for one last
question here
i think this is a question that anybody
could answer
um so and i'd love to hear what all
different folks think about that so
what are some strategies to maintain
consistency in file locations on the
server for data
databases our scripts our markdown
projects and dashboards
um we have issues with files everywhere
but no structure
so what are some tips that you might
have on maintaining that consistency
um i'll i'll go ahead just real quick so
i think a really great solution for this
is to use a project-based workflow
if you look up the tidyverse blog jenny
bryan has a great article
on using a project-based workflow and so
what this allows you to do is to sort of
make projects more self-contained
i think that's a really great place to
start obviously that there are other
tools in terms of sort of like
consolidating data and database access
and and some things like that
uh but starting with a project-based
workflow i think is a really powerful
first step
to to making things sort of more
projects uh and and and work more
self-contained that in a package right a
project and a package go together really
nicely
for keeping things self-contained
two points from my side that i would add
um
if you want to have a great
clean code with within just one
application
i'd recommend learning about different
designs for example domain driven design
is a great way of structuring
projects and it applies to many
different languages
there is plenty of books about it and
they actually give you a good overview
on how you can
build your functions your files so that
they are understandable to everyone
and the other suggestion is to use
different external tools
so if you make sure that for example
there is a package manager that has the
all of the packages available for you
there is a specified way of deploying
applications that is for example
automated then the more you have
the more structure you provide to you to
your developers
the easier it will be for them to find
the right way to do things so just
creating for example a
definition of done how things are done
within the organization
how you organize your work and sharing
it with others
can be you enough to actually have a
very good
clean code within your different
projects
um what i think is also useful is to
is to follow so you can have a style
guide
for for structuring your code
but nothing stops you from having a
document
which also describes the best practices
how to structure your project and if you
see
um a repetitive pattern you can
extract this pattern and create a
template
from which which you will initialize
every new project so basically
the knowledge that you accumulated in
the past projects can be quite
easily um transferred to a new project
um so this is something from my side
that's great thank you all so much for
answering these questions
thank you everyone thanks everyone thank
you
thanks everybody